so you gave me your solution I'm going
to give you my solution so my solution
is burn the whole thing down my solution
is that we need to build new things we
need to build new institutions so this
I'm going to burn a tremendous number of
bridges when I say this I'm just going
to tell you because I'm going to speak
you're in a burning mood I'm I'm in a
burning I've been in a burn mood for
quite a while yeah but I
um and I don't mean burn them down
physically of course I mean let them
fall into further delegitimizing
themselves because they're they're not
legitimate
how do we get Beyond how do we speak
bluntly about facts and evidence without
having the Democrats go berserk or the
Republicans go berserk how do we just
say listen these this is the data we
need to make the best available the best
policies based upon the best available
evidence without people losing their
freaking Minds like I don't know and
well I do have a theory on that no go
ahead I mean it's what we're doing here
in Florida
which is we have a highly competent
government that is run by someone who is
clearly articulating what their beliefs
are and when they try to bring crazy
trans gender identity into schools nope
we're not going to do that when they try
to connect woke ideology to
African-American studies no we're not
going to do that we're not going to let
a place like Disney with zero tolerance
for madness yeah and so I think that
that actually is the only answer I don't
know at a societal level a Country-Wide
level I don't know that that yeah sort
of scale that or at least from the top I
guess my concern is and I haven't been
following that coaching my concern is I
would want to make sure that no speech
would be quelched in that process so if
you want to have someone spouting
some idiocy like critical race Theory
that's fine and I know I have
significant disagreements with people on
this
you know I I think I initially said you
know you wouldn't have people if someone
wants to you know scream about phenology
about the Earth being 5 000 years old
but these are dangerous divisive toxic
and racist beliefs there's also a
difference between talking about them
and teaching them yeah you can talk
about the Nazis you wouldn't want to
teach Nazi ideology correct and testing
people in terms of the right ideas that
students that answered back right that
Accords with the ideological precepts so
I'm I'm concerned about that I haven't I
have so you gave me your solution I'm
going to give you my solution so my
solution is burn the whole thing down my
solution is that we need to build new
things we need to build new institutions
so this I'm going to burn a tremendous
number of bridges when I say this I'm
just going to tell you because I'm an
engineered a speaker you're in a burning
mood I'm I'm in a burning I've been in a
burn mood for quite a while now but I
um and I don't mean burn them down
physically of course I mean let them
fall into further delegitimizing
themselves because they're they're not
legitimate basically you're saying give
them a push they're on the way so every
single attempt at saving them or
fighting for free speech or this guy got
canceled because he showed a picture of
the Prophet Muhammad which by the way is
on Wikipedia that now certain countries
don't want on and if you look at the
Islamic Wikipedia still if you go to the
museums in Turkey there are uh drawings
of the Muslim Prophet Muhammad but
bracketing that for Assad as an aside
any attempt to fix or solve the problem
is only slowing it down the problem
cannot be solved we have tremendous Dei
bureaucracies we have people who have
jobs for life we have College of
Education that are the worst of the
worst
we have to build new things we have
University of Austin Ralston College
Peterson is building a new platform
that's the solution to this problem let
let them just fall into what let them
get what they deserve well a I agree
with that I had Stephen Blackwood in
that very chair talking about Ralston
and he's obviously doing that with
Jordan what's happening here in Florida
now with Chris Ruffo is going to sit on
the board of I believe it's new school
on the west coast and they're gonna
try to fix what's going on over because
even in Florida our institutions were
captured by this stuff too how important
is it do you think I mean as someone
that you care deeply about Academia I
mean how important is it that kids even
go to college at this point
I think the bet well let me just back up
saying yeah wokism is a universal
solvent it will destroy everything and
anything it touches and so I'm
incredibly sympathetic to having a zero
like the hungarians have a zero policy
there's like we're letting none of this
in like zero yeah so the best answer to
your question is what I told my kids you
know my kids uh I told my daughter who
wants to go to college don't do it be an
electrician
oh that's the other thing I tweeted last
night we need to be talking more about
vocational that education absolutely
vital what did your daughter say to that
she entertained it but she wants to go
to college and I I can't say it I'm
disappointed like I will do you know I
want her to live her life and pursue it
my parents paid for my education
although at the time it wasn't an
ideology meal but I I think uh my advice
to to young kids would be
and it's not to go to a conservative
University like Liberty the the solution
to this stuff
to ideological capture is not to create
institutions that have the opposite
ideology the creation the solutions to
create new institutions that are
truth-based that have genuine
intellectual diversity so uh my my
suggestion would be to send your kids to
vocational vocational school yeah it's
interesting on on the Liberty Front I'm
only mentioning this because I was
invited there I spoke at their Sunday
convocation yeah 14
000 kids huge huge absolute fourteen
thousand uh they know I'm married to a
man they know as I still describe myself
but begrudgingly pro-choice there's a
couple other things that I certainly am
not a traditional conservative on right
Standing Ovation from these kids spent
the entire day walking around the
schooling taking selfies with kids yeah
I want to give you a hug for that but
we're on followers I think Lindsay was
the only person who was an atheist who's
ever been invited to speak before so
what what does that tell you then about
the conservative even in this case and
you as a guy that wrote a book called
Emanuel for creating atheists you spend
an awful lot of time around religious
people now awful
so your primary allies seem to be from
what I can tell Christian conservatives
correct and sort of more I don't know
people from maybe a more nationalist
political Camp certainly than than you
consider yourself from or something like
that people like that Mark Andreessen
who just basically think that the system
is corrupt like I do and I need to build
you know that's the new culture War by
the way Legacy institutions versus
building new things old Universe like
sub stack versus New York Times Wall
Street Journal Etc okay locals perfect
so 100 new things that's well you're a
builder I lost the threat of the
conversation what so well this odd
Alliance that you're now in as someone
that was right that you were literally
your mission at first at least at one
time was to create atheists I also do
want to talk about how the atheist
movement has seen me collapse but let's
pause on that for a second so that your
allies are now the people that you maybe
used to wanna
convert yeah so I think while I've never
converted anyone I just gave them the
tools to convert themselves just to be
clear so I think that this cultural War
2.0 is very different from 1.0 and I
published a piece in this in the
American mind years ago but excuse me
it's
we're unified in objective truth that
you can figure out what it is that you
can find it we're unified on the Rules
of Engagement so the Rules of Engagement
is if you if someone gives a talk and
you don't like to talk you don't blow a
bull horn at the talk like they're
irrational civil ways to adjudicate
disputes you know legal mechanisms
framework if you don't like the statue
here in Miami I don't know some in
Portland they destroyed a deer statue
right you you go through Democratic
means and have I mean I couldn't care
less what statues are there but you
don't take the law into your own hands
to quit Judge Judy uh so so there's an
agreement that there are mechanisms that
we can go to to figure out how to solve
civil issue civil disputes so that's the
other thing right so are you shocked
though even at this point even though
we've been if people go back and watch
our videos from six years ago yeah uh
they'll find us talking about these same
things me from a more Lefty perspective
as well but the point is are you shocked
that there's virtually no liberals
obviously not none and Omar is doing it
and I know you know two or three others
yeah but what you're talking about are
no they're liberal principles not
defended by liberals that's correct
that's correct and I think that what
conservative and liberalism shifted but
I'm going to suggest a new access to you
the new access is and um Andrew my
friend Andrew our friend Andrew Doyle
wrote about that book in his book the
new Puritans the new the axis of the way
to think about these problems isn't
liberal conservative right left it's
authoritarian non-authoritarian and the
most important thing is cognitive
Liberty we have to enable people to live
like in London they're arresting people
for praying I mean I think anybody
should be able to talk to themselves
anywhere they want if I want to talk to
myself it'd be a lot if I started
talking to myself right now right now
the idea the idea that you would arrest
somebody for that you have a group of
people the woke people the dominant
moral Orthodoxy who wants to tell you
exactly what to think and if you don't
think it you're a problem right that we
we need some kind of a struggle session
we need to somehow correct this we need
to intervene we need to have you know
government and sponsorships programs
interventions I suggest the access in
the culture War
is best thought of as authoritarians
versus not right so basically there's
there's authoritarians or Libertarians
not meaning you're a Libertarian card
caring member of the libertarian party
but you you either want control or you
don't want control something yeah and
you want to let I want to let people
pursue whatever lives they want to lead
I I think the same thing but so you
acknowledge that that that that is far
more rich on the right or the
conservative side of the aisle now right
I will acknowledge that the left has a
terrible problem
that is not that is Unthinkable among
traditional leftists that it's been
prosthetized by wokeism it's been
proselytized by an invasive ideology I
wrote about that in my first book
um that is not inherent in the left and
you know it's guilt by association it's
not even guilt that I'm here it'd be
like somebody else won't talk to me
Zello you've been untucked I've been on
Tucker Carlson twice so you won't run oh
you were on Reuben's show you well so
what like
so yeah there's no question that there's
a tremendous problem with that
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about Academia
check out our Academia playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell